now do people the companies ever come to
you and say hey man you're really good
at reviewing these things are we [ __ ]
up here kinda sorta red came to me
before this existed in its in this form
and it wasn't a prototype phase and they
were still pretty far along but it was
kind of like should we do this like
should we put this here
should we keep the headphone jack I was
I was giving them sort of yeah they kept
the headphone jack little things like
that but for the most part I think what
a lot of people don't understand about
product development is it happens many
many many many months before you ever
see the products show up so I don't know
if your member like all the leaks about
the pixel 3xl all of them guarantees six
months before the phone came out it was
done yeah like they knew that that's
what it was good more than I think any
phone that I can recall yeah so like
that's the same as the iPhone like
they've been working on the whatever the
next iPhone is they've been working on
that iPhone and it's probably gonna be
like a couple more months and then
they're like finalizing design and
things like that and so when you start
to see phones come out like around like
September and October and they start to
all kind of resemble each other and then
another one comes out and it looks the
same it's not like they saw the phone in
early October and they were like let's
copy that and then they made the next
phone two weeks later they've been
working on this forever so like one the
whole like the whole notch thing was you
know people were like oh I hope Google's
trolling us and that's not really the
notch and they're gonna have this phone
with no notch no it's they've been
working on this for a long time this is
what they planned